Mike how important of a role does a man
a strong man play in a boy's life when
he's trying to find himself well um you
know you have to think about what
perception of the strong man he could be
a strong man and a criminalist
perspective in the legal perspective and
that could be the strongest um identity
that he sees and so he can go off in
that level of crime as well but it's all
about um and when I say that
even if people in crime they're great
men I won't say they're all good men but
they're great men and so um if we could
really concentrate on doing the best we
can from our perspective of being a good
man and transform that into other
children other young boys that will be a
start Michael you're seeing right now
messages on YouTube go viral where it's
grown men like Jordan Peterson talk
about what it is to be a man or even
Andrew Tates talking to young boys there
seems to be a you know in every industry
there's a sect of that industry does
very well like hey in books young
non-fiction is doing really well right
now really youth nonfiction yes kids
want to know more okay interesting you
know in the denomination of religion hey
the LDS church has grown at the space
runner really why what are they doing
hey when it comes down to Content being
creative right now young boys want to
learn from a man with experience maybe
they don't have a father figure growing
up why do you think that content is
resonating the way it is with young boys
because of the fact that you know
there's a there's an effort to demean
what a real man is today if I see it
that way anyhow you know and when people
look up to a guy that presents himself
like a man then it's attractive to them
you know look one of the reasons Patrick
I go into prisoners I talk to these
young gang bangers you know and they'll
say to me come on Michael you had the
great cause you had the women you know
you you wore the right clothing to them
that's what a man looks like so they
want the image of a man you know a
manhood but you know the problem is a
lot of people today think that when
you're telling a man how to be a man
that it's demeaning to a woman they've
they've made that a part of of uh
Society now well if you're telling this
guy to be a man that means he's a good
demean women and I said no a real man is
going to benefit women women are going
to benefit by that because you're going
to treat her the right way you know he's
going to bring up his kids properly he's
gonna you know he's going to be in the
community do the right thing that's what
a man is it's not you know being a macho
guy or anything like that of course you
gotta defend yourself man protects his
women of course
but you know there's just the idea of a
man has been changed today it really has
and and that's what we uh we want to
teach guys oh look a man can be
sensitive a man can have emotion you
know there's nothing wrong with that you
know how many times look I want to what
the most powerful guys you want to see I
see him crying at a funeral they go to a
a show and they got tears in the rise on
an opera show I've seen that there's
nothing wrong with that you're showing
emotion you know it's
you know and I think these young guys
today are really looking for that yeah
you know and they look they look at
somebody like Mike who let me tell you
something you know the way he came up
and to be where he is today it's a
miracle it really is you know under the
odds that he had to face in that way you
know mine is different I didn't go
through the some of the things that he
went it was different for me but uh you
know the fact that I'm here you know
this Patrick I should be dead or in
prison a long time ago it's just been
very fortunate you know so we want to
use these experiences to try to help
people and that's what this is all about
and uh and we're going to do it I fully
agree with what Michael's saying is that
there's just such a need for leadership
uh for young men these days I guess my
question is
it's not a zero-sum game like for
forever we've heard that it's the
patriarchy and this is this is basically
has given a rise to modern day feminism
and then you see things like the future
is female where it's like what is that
if the future is female what does that
mean for men right and then you see
things like the feminism and the boss
babe movement and everything with that
it's men and women can both win right I
think women want a strong man in their
life and men want a you know what's the
famous phrase behind every great man
there's a strong woman so how can men
and women win in today's society what do
you think well listen that's gonna be
pretty difficult
because when you watch television you
see it could be black people could be
white it's confrontation between man and
woman that's what you see on television
that's what you see on housewives show
that's just what you see you see this on
um Kevin Samuel so you see this on
sometimes what's the other guy Andrew
take it's just confrontation
confrontation cells and we're not gonna
stop this conversation this is gonna
become an error so we can continue to
make money off of people's pain so
whether it's Republicans Or democrats
whether it's blacks and whites whether
it's men and women it's just going to
constantly be doubling down on this
against each other if you want to see
the future of a country look at his
advertisement
what does it advertise damn you know
what that makes me think of right so
about how we're the only guys sit there
and you just made two profound comments
in the last minute what about you know
how United States and I think New
Zealand are the only countries that big
Pharma is allowed to advertise on so
when you see the opioid uh endemic
that's going on right now I think Mike
Tyson makes up a great point it's that
if you want to see the future of a
country look at the advertising how many
people are on big families now look at
the MC family before like taboos to mix
a black or Italian a black Asian Spanish
that was taboo you think but now it's
promoting this is what it's going to be
because you see the influx of different
um I'm not good immigrants immigrants
coming in the country and that and
they're showing this is what it's going
to look at and they're preparing us they
put in the televisions or movies you
know and that's what we're preparing for
because people know the society knows
that run the place
um American black white Asians they
don't stay kindly to um immigrants we
just don't I don't know why because when
the Irish was here like in the 1800s and
when Irish they were called Real
Americans but when the Irish came from
Ireland they crushed them they made them
the enemy how could you do that that
means if I came out they made these guys
the enemy
so they can take advantage to them and
Rob them so they made these guys you
don't have to have any feelings so much
someone like slaves yeah
we have human nature what other
advertisements you see on TV that are
shocking to you like that's a profound
statement you said if you want to see a
future country look at the advertising
what else do you see on TV well some
things I'd rather than not talk about
okay you know that um it's you know it's
just interesting you know um
it's just what it is I guess so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]